eigentlich ist ja alles ganz klar die
spiralarme von galaxien bewegen sich zu
schnell eigentlich müssten sie wenn man
sich die materie ansieht die sie
enthalten viel langsamer um das zentrum
der galaxien kreisen als sie es tun und
das ist überall im universum so die
einzige erklärung von der nahezu alle
physiker ausgehen es gibt mehr als die
sichtbare materie die dunkle materie
aber bisher wurde sie einfach nicht
gefunden niemand hat irgendetwas
entdeckt dass sie sein könnte sie
versteckt sich einfach könnte sie
vielleicht gar nicht existieren jetzt
sind klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
schon 1983 stellte der israelische
physiker morde heim in rom eine
umstrittene theorie auf gibt es
vielleicht gar keine dunkle materie
er wusste noch nichts von der
jahrzehntelangen vergeblichen suche nach
der dunkle materie bis zum heutigen tage
ist kein teilchen der dunklen materie
gefunden worden
dabei sollte der großteil des universums
oder ein erheblicher teil des universums
aus dunkler materie bestehen
23 prozent des universums wären dunkle
materie 4,6 prozent die uns bekannte
materie und 72% dunkle energie
wenn aber die fünffache menge verglichen
mit der bekannten materie dunkle materie
werden das müssen sie doch irgendwie
aufzuspüren sein aber pustekuchen es ist
nicht das geringste zu finden aber wo
versteckt sie sich nur oder tut sie das
gar nicht nur daheim hatte 1983 eine
andere idee und sie ist verblüffend
einleuchten warum erzähle ich gleich
erstmal die idee er hat das newtons
gravitationsgesetz bei kleinen
beschleunigungen modifiziert und
ausprobiert was passiert wenn er eine
neue konstante einführt 0 heißt sie und
es ist wirklich ziemlich beeindruckend
was dann passiert seine idee nennt sich
modifizierte newtonsche dynamik kurz nd
mond und kommt bei extrem kleinen
beschleunigung durch die gravitation zum
tragen wie sie eben in den äußeren armen
einer galaxie existiert das frappierende
er hat sich viele galaxien angesehen und
kann immer wieder auf den gleichen wert
für 1 0 1,2 mal 10 hoch minus zehn meter
pro sekunde im quadrat also ein immens
kleiner wert 10 stellen hinter dem komma
die app beschleunigung zum vergleich
liegt bei 9,81 meter pro sekunde im
quadrat riesig dagegen ab diesem wert
also ab dem kleinen nullwert und das
gilt für alle achtung alle galaxien
bleibt die rotationsgeschwindigkeit um
das zentrum der galaxien gleich immer
und dazu und das macht diese theorie für
die physik so interessant ist sie
elegant den mond ermöglicht es die
materien den galaxien hilfsweise über
das abgestrahlte licht zu bestimmen und
damit die rotationsgeschwindigkeit
auszurechnen und es stimmt ich sehe mir
eine galaxie an und weiß wie sie sich
bewegt
das heißt diese theorie ist ganz einfach
durch die beobachtete
rotationsgeschwindigkeit der galaxien im
weltraum belegt es gibt nur einen haken
warum ist das so baum gibt es diese
konstante es gibt keine erklärung aber
eigentlich gilt das ja auch für die
dunkle materie ist gibt keinen beweis
und die dunkle materie die für eine
galaxie angenommen wird ist bei weitem
nicht so einfach zu bestimmen wie mond
die rotationsgeschwindigkeit ermittelt
aber es gibt eine galaxie die ganz klar
nicht durch mondt erklärt werden kann
dass bullet cluster eigentlich sind es
zwei galaxien der mal kollidiert sind
aber und das ist echt verrückt auch die
theorie der dunkle materie funktioniert
hier nicht richtig
der letzte astronomen der universität
basel oliver müller hat in einem beitrag
für science blog jetzt viele andere
beispiele von lange angenommenen
irrtümern der wissenschaft angeführt hat
nec hielten sich diese theorien wie sie
einfach nicht mehr zu halten waren dabei
ist wichtig festzustellen dass die
dunkle materie bisher nur eine hypothese
ist sie ist zwar als sehr wahrscheinlich
in der für sie akzeptiert aber noch
wurde keinerlei beweis gefunden müller
erinnert an die theorie der alten
griechen wonach sich die planeten um die
erde drehten
jede beobachtung führte allerdings dazu
dass die theorie nicht mehr so ganz
passte und mit jeder beobachtungen
wurden neue hilfs hypothesen aufgestellt
irgendwann passt aber gar nichts mehr
und eine neue erkenntnis brach sich bahn
ja die planeten kreist um die sonne oder
im 19 jahrhundert wurde der planet
vulkan erfunden um die bewegungen von
merkur um die sonne zu erklären die
wissenschaft besteht aus versuch und
irrtum und nur wenn eine hypothese
bestätigt wird ist sie war und bei der
dunkle materie gibt es noch keine
bestätigung wer weiß vielleicht wird sie
es nie geben weil die dunkle materie
nicht existiert und vielleicht ist es
dann doch mode ich halte euch dazu auf
jeden fall auf dem laufen wenn ihr kein
video zur dunkle materie oder mond
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein
aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke damit er nichts verpasst
hier geht es weiter mit neue
erkenntnisse zur dunklen materie
dann gibt es wieder in diensten für die
dunkle materie draufklicken es bleibt
spannend also bis dann bleibt dran